[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
good evening I'm Stuart brand from the
long now foundation and we're doing a
serious long now tonight here we have a
mathematical physicist who's doing
something that is really at the core of
what the long now foundation has been
trying to get at and I think I first saw
a version of it back when I was a
skydiver in the 1960s and the thing
about skydiving is when you're in the
plane somebody jumps out there right
there in the wind and they get real
small and when it's you jumping out
you're out there in the wind and you
push the plane away and it gets real
small and that's pretty much how we live
in time but one time there was two
planes two sticks of jumpers and I was
in one plane watching the guys jump out
of the other plane guy gets out on the
strut lets go and plummets
I'd never seen skydiving from the side
before it was horrifying shortly after
that I had a malfunction which tried to
kill me and failed but that the
combination of those two events made me
stop skydiving and I'm here today I
learned we seldom do that with time in a
sense what John bias is here to do
tonight is look at time not from within
and we're we're telescoping out in one
direction telescoping out in the other
direction but looking at it from the
side and seeing what kind of patterns
emerge there and how you can get a
handle on things from that perspective
or you might do something about them if
you don't happen to like them please
welcome John bys
[Applause]
thanks very much it's great to be here
Stuart brand and Kevin Kelly have been
heroes of mine and so it's nice to be
able to talk to them even if I'm
standing up here uh and the rest of you
of course so I'm a mathematical
physicist so I usually think about
things that are either bigger than that
or smaller than you can see but I
thought I'd do something a little bit
more human and scale and talk about
history and the weather and so right now
we're in a very strange moment in
history things are changing
mighty fast these days as you I'm sure
I've heard there's this thing called
Moore's law talking about how computers
are working ever faster but really
that's just a tiny bit of a much bigger
story which you can see may be pretty
well on this graph here a lot has been
happening in the last couple hundred
years and it blinds us to the overall
scope of time so this is a graph of
population starting from approximately
around the end of the last ice age till
now and you'll see that it ramped up in
retrospect fairly slowly until the
second Agricultural Revolution when
machines stood modern machines started
getting used for agriculture and then it
shot up and so if you were tonight
extrapolate a trend from this curve
you'd conclude that in about thirty
years from now the population of the
world will become infinite and that's
the singularity when the earth collapses
into a black hole under the weight of
all the people well we can tell that
that's probably not really gonna happen
it would be against the laws of physics
so you chose you have to be a little
careful when you're extrapolating
Irv's and luckily if you were able to
zoom in on the top of this curve a lot
more fine finally then we have accuracy
here you see to your relief that it's
beginning to slope down slightly and
it's not sloped down slope up less fast
so there's a little hope for us but the
problem I want to talk about is not the
what's going to be the most likely
continuation of this curve it just has
to do with trying to understand time on
a large scale trying to understand
history when we're standing right here
is a lot like trying to understand
geography when you're hanging on to a
cliff you you you think of geography as
vertical but at most of it's not but you
just can't see it and you're scared
stiff so I want to zoom out a bit and
see what history is like on a slightly
larger scale and of course history is
incredibly complicated so I thought I'd
focus on something that we all know
something about namely the weather so
the weather is a hot topic these days
because all this rapid expansion in
human population and other things like
technology goes along with burning stuff
we basically fuel our existence these
days by burning carp and just like the
population curve shoots up all of a
sudden in the last two centuries or so
same for the co2 carbon dioxide
emissions mainly from burning oil coal
and gas as you can see here but you can
see how remarkably it's it's shot up
from what looks like nothing to quite a
lot and of course that has an effect on
things that has an effect on the weather
it has an effect on the air first of all
so here's a graph over the last 40 years
I guess of how much carbon dioxide there
is in the air the red curve is the real
thing measured in Hawaii the blue curve
is sort of an averaged out version of
that and you can see it's been going up
of course you can make any graph look
scary if you plot it correctly so you
should always be careful and look at the
bottom of the graph here so it's not
starting from zero don't blame me if ur
for making this graph I would like to
start things at zero and make it look a
little less scary but still it's pretty
scary because it's gone from 300 parts
per million to about 400 parts per
million in the last 40 years so that
means there's about a 30% increase in
the amount of carbon dioxide in the air
over the just the last 40 years and as
we'll see 40 years is a pathetically
small amount of time over the if you
measured in geological timescale so for
the Earth's atmosphere to change so
drastically in such a short time it's
really a unprecedented thing or almost
unprecedented thing so that's what I
want to talk about of course you've
heard a lot about global warming but
unfortunately usually what you hear
about it only focuses on a tiny sliver
of history which doesn't really give you
enough of a view of it to really see
what what it's what it's what its
impacts or what its significance is just
in case you're curious the wiggly red
curve there has to do with the fact that
there's an annual cycle in how much
carbon dioxide there is in the air most
of the plants live in the northern
hemisphere and so when it's summer in
the northern hemisphere they they eat up
carbon dioxide and the carbon dioxide
goes down and then during the winter it
goes back up and all this is very
beautifully
visible in that graph but anyway the
increase in carbon dioxide goes along
with increase in temperature because
infrared radiation leaving the the earth
trying to get back out to space gets
absorbed by carbon dioxide and so we've
been seeing an increase in temperature
ever since the Industrial Revolution
roughly 1860 here in this graph and you
can see it's a very complicated wiggly
curve the blue curve is the real thing
the red curve
averaged out so you get a more of a
sense of it but you can see anyway that
its temperature averaged over the whole
world has gone up eight tenths of a
degree centigrade or I guess that's
something like one and a half degrees
Fahrenheit over the last I guess roughly
150 years and that's a big deal but it
doesn't sound like a big deal when you
first hear about it if someone says well
the temperature went up one and a half
degrees you say well that's no big deal
but you the reason why you can't tell
even whether it is a big deal or not
it's because we're looking on such a
short time scale so to see what's really
going on we have to zoom out to a larger
time scale to see if this is just some
random wiggle that's it'll go away or
what so let's zoom out a little bit here
so instead of just looking at the last
150 years let's look at the last fifteen
thousand years or so and see what
temperature has been doing this is
actually the temperature in Greenland
temperatures up in places like Greenland
are much more variable than than near
the equator so this is or shows some
drastic variations they'd be less if you
measured it near the equator but anyway
you can get the picture pretty clearly
this is all from digging a two mile deep
I score in the glaciers in Greenland
that let you go back and see yearly
variations in various various things
like the isotope concentration in the
ice and get a sense of the temperature
over that time period and you'll see the
main thing here is that there had been
an ice age till around 12,000 years ago
and then it warmed up and it's been
surprisingly even in temperature ever
since
so we've lived meaning we the we of
recorded human history we've lived in a
sort of false sense of security in in
terms of thinking that the climates more
or less constant when in fact if you go
back just a little bit further you see
there are much more jagged variations in
temperature so
that rise in temperature that I showed
you on the last slide is just a tiny
little thing right there and so if you
look at that then you might say well gee
what are people worried about about
global warming maybe what we should be
worried about the next ice age instead
and that's sort of true but we'll we'll
see there are different views you can
take on this I just want to talk about a
couple Wiggles on this curve so I'll
first I'll talk about a tiny little
wiggle called the Little Ice Age which
is a little dent right phone next to
that bump there but because it's fairly
recent it has its own name whereas most
of these Wiggles of course don't have
any name and then I want to talk about a
more interesting well not more
interesting the more substantial wiggle
which is called the Younger Dryas
episode so right as the last ice age was
ending for it was it was warming up then
the temperature plunged around 13,000
years ago and that's an interesting
story in itself
so let's just take a look at those and
we get a sense of what kind of things
the climate can do so the Little Ice Age
was from around 1550 to 1850 and the
temperatures in Europe dropped about one
degree centigrade so that's one one one
and a half degrees or so
Fahrenheit near the equator apparently
it was a bigger deal it was about a two
degree change but it was noticed by
people at the time just due to the fact
that winters were colder than they had
been and people have done studies of
paintings the history of paintings and
they find more of these kind of scenes
during that stretch of time there's a
lot of controversy over how big a deal
that that fluctuation was that is how
much it actually mattered in particular
it's an interesting question because it
ended right when the industrial
revolution started around 1850 so we may
have ended the Little Ice Age by pumping
lots of carbon dioxide out into the air
so maybe it wouldn't have been so little
if we hadn't done something about
regardless of whether we wanted to he
did so that's a little wiggle it makes
it makes people be able to walk around
on the ice in the winter in the
Netherlands whereas now they can't but a
bigger wiggle was this Younger Dryas
episode which began about twelve
thousand nine hundred years ago so that
was a shocking event in only 20 years
the temperature in Europe dropped by
seven degrees centigrade on average and
that lasted for a thousand years and
then suddenly in another 20 years it
ended so what seven degrees mean well
seven degrees means that France and
Germany became tundra and Scotland had
glaciers on it and you can see if you
can read these not too readable letters
that the climate was really drastically
different in Europe than it is now so
our ancestors who are just beginning to
practice agriculture and around that
time had to put up with a thousand years
of cold really really cold weather and
luckily I guess it didn't kill us off we
just made do and then all of a sudden in
another 20 years it popped right back up
to what we know now so this is an
interesting question why did that happen
no one really knows why it happened
there's a theory which is interesting
which goes like this so you've all heard
that the reason why Europe is warmer
than a comparable place up here in
Canada is because the Gulf Stream
carries heat from the southern latitudes
up past the coast of Europe in fact it's
I just heard recently that that's
somewhat controversial among among
scientists these days they've really
been trying to understand exactly what's
going on and it's not as clear as you
might think
but according to this theory which I'm
telling you which was a popular theory
for a while the key to understanding the
Younger Dryas was this current flow
which which keeps Europe warm and an
interesting thing happened which is that
towards the end of the last ice age
Canada was covered with glaciers and so
the edge of those glaciers there was a
lot of glacial runoff
melted ice formed lakes and there was a
huge lake called Lake Agassiz 's which
is that light blue thing there which is
by now shrunk down to smaller Lakes like
Lake Winnipeg so in Manitoba there but
this lake was huge and it was blocked
from flowing to the sea by ice was
blocked by lots of ice but it's known
that several times it actually managed
to erode its way through that ice and
there were huge floods where the lake
emptied out through the st. Lawrence
Seaway and up into the north poured out
into the North Atlantic this is known
through studies of sediment at the
bottom of the North Atlantic there are
actually lots of periods when when this
this Lake would bust free and carry lots
of rocks and it'd be layers of sediment
but it's possible that the freshwater
from that lake was enough to screw up
the Gulf Stream and ironically the
melting led Europe to get a lot colder
because the Gulf Stream was blocked so
in fact if I had given this talk about 6
months ago I would have just said this
is the truth this is how it works but
recently people have started doubting
that for various reasons both because
they don't think the Gulf Stream is
quite so significant and also because
they've done a lot of ice cores in
mountains in
the tropics there are some mountains
like Mount Kilimanjaro and other less
famous ones that have ice even though
they're in the tropics and they
discovered that the younger driest
episode was just as pronounced there and
maybe even came before its appearance in
northern Europe and which would mean
that there was some other cause perhaps
for why Europe got frozen so that's just
I think a mystery at this point it's a
pretty important mystery though because
suppose it was fresh water pouring into
the North Atlantic that made Europe get
cold for a thousand years well then we
should be a little bit concerned because
that's what's happening now right now
Greenland and the Arctic are melting so
there's a picture of how Greenland has
been melting over the last 10 years and
down below here's a picture of of the
Arctic melting away from 1979 to 2005
these are pictures during the summer
when the ice is at its minimum and
you'll see that there's a significant
amount of change there in particular now
there's something called the Northwest
Passage you may have heard about it if
you heard about old explorers who are
trying to find some sneaky quick route
to get from Europe to the western United
States by sailing north of Russia well
back when they were looking for the
Northwest Passage it didn't exist
because it was snow blocked through ice
blocked at all times of the year but now
it does exist and now in fact oil
companies are taking advantage of it to
ship their oil during the summer months
north of Russia of course they helped
create it maybe it's just all part of an
elaborate business plan I don't know but
but this is a significant amount of
melting if you think about it especially
if you have to imagine yourself thinking
on the scale of thousands of years the
Ice Age is ended 10,000 years ago now
here we see in just 30 years the the
remaining bit of the polar ice cap is
shrunk significantly so people have
noticed that there is a lot more fresh
water going into the Atlantic the
salinity is going down and some people
are worried that it could trigger
another Younger Dryas event but we don't
really know so we don't know if that's
going to happen but to get a better
perspective on this kind of thing we
have to zoom out a lot further just
looking at the last ice age really isn't
nearly enough to tell what's going on
it's just like you know just looking at
the last night you say oh yes there was
a period of night and ever since then
it's been day well that that's sort of
the attitude that people have in fact we
have this silly geological timing system
this is a great book this book is not
silly it's called the Holocene the
Holocene is unnamed for a geological
period though which is the period after
the last ice age and that's sort of like
having a name for the day and then
before that it was night or something
like that it's just it's the geological
periods gets shrunk in a silly way when
they get near to the point when we show
up on the scene anyway we have to zoom
out to see what's going on so 150 years
ago we have the Industrial Revolution
and the start of this human-caused
warming 1,500 years ago well there were
widespread empires 15,000 years ago
that's around the tail end of the last
ice age as we've seen so the Younger
Dryas kicked in around 13,000 years ago
but you need to zoom out a few more
powers of 10 to really see what's going
on so you have to go out a hundred and
fifty thousand years ago to get to the
tail end of the previous ice age so ice
ages have been going on for a while and
they happen roughly in a very irregular
way about every hundred thousand years
or so so you really have to see a number
of them before you can tell what's going
on the ice ages started the serious ice
ages started around 1,000 sorry one and
a half million years ago so that means
there's been about ten ice ages since
then and but but but the ice ages didn't
start all of a sudden there was a period
of cooling as we'll see that it's lasted
for quite a bit
longer than that so if you got another
power of 10 you get 215 million years
ago and the cooling of the Earth's
climate was well underway at that time
that's when apes just began to split off
from other kinds of kinds of monkeys and
so we have to look at all these
timescales which you notice are
significantly different powers of 10
here to see what's going on with the
climate so let's zoom out a little bit
and see what we see so here's a bunch of
graphs illustrating the climate at
different time scales so down at the
bottom here is the last 150 years so
this is measured in Killough atoms or
thousands of years so so that's 150
years there and you can so that's
basically roughly since the Industrial
Revolution and you can see it's been
warming up with lots of wiggles and it's
been warming up approximately a degree
in that amount of time as I said but
okay that's way too small to see
anything interesting so let's zoom out
by one power sorry
no resuming out here by two powers of 10
and jump up two powers of 10 so this is
16,000 years so that's the end of the
last ice age here's the Younger Dryas
and here's this nice Wiggly fairly
constant weather we've been having ever
since and you can see it's warmed up
about 5 degrees since the end of the
last ice age but we have to zoom out
further so ok let's zoom out to go back
a hundred and fifty thousand years ago
then you see that all this warming up
that's been going on is this little
thing here and you see that in the last
150 thousand years basically what
happened is we had an ice age it got
very cold and then zoom-in warmed up so
the way this particular last ice age
went was it warmed up suddenly cooled
down and then warmed up suddenly but
that's just one of 10 ice ages
approximately 10 ice ages that's
happened in the last
million years so well you can't really
count ice ages as you see here counting
ice ages is counting the number of dents
in this picture but you have to decide
how big they have to be to count it's
just a very complicated thing so there's
the last ice age but you can see that
there have been a bunch of them and so
that's what's been going on but that's
still a bit mysterious because it makes
you wonder well how long has it been
going on like that and what happened
before that so let's zoom out a bit more
we really have to zoom out quite a bit
more to see what's really going on so
here I'm zooming out to 65 million years
ago so the stuff I showed you before was
just this period called rapid glacial
cycles just this little bit here was
what I was showing you before 65 million
years ago is a good time to start
because that's when the dinosaurs went
extinct in a rather dramatic manner and
so this has been sort of the era of of
mammals and you can see some interesting
stuff has been going on in the last 65
million years
so basically in a nutshell it warmed up
for a while and then cooled down quite a
lot it warmed up till around 55 million
years ago interestingly paleontologists
talk about an optimum when it's as warm
as possible for some reason they'd like
it to be warm so so from their point of
view you think of global warming yay so
but so the optimum so to speak or
maximum I prefer to call it happened 55
million years ago it cooled down and
then boom it took a big dive around 35
million years ago that's when the
antarctic froze over
so for through most of the history of
the earth there haven't been ice caps
around this time there were crocodiles
in Antarctica and palm trees and ferns
so the formation of the ice caps in the
north and south pole happened around
then and so that's a big interesting
puzzle why did it happen we're used to
it but it's an unusual thing it melted
the Antarctic melted for a while and
then it froze over again and it's been
getting colder ever since but even more
interesting in a way than the fact that
it's getting colder is that the
temperature variations have been getting
bigger you notice the curve gets really
jittery near the edge here so we're at a
time period that's quite a bit colder
than most of the history of the earth
and also much more erratic these Wiggles
happening about every hundred thousand
years ago or so every hundred thousand
years or so so the Holocene is probably
to that little black vertical line right
at the edge of the graph that's
so-called present the deep that's what
they call it the present the nice period
of time eventually if humanity lives
long ago to say well back in the present
it's gonna be a sort of embarrassing
terminology it's sort of like
post-modernism so anyway the the period
of these big ice ages is called the the
Pleistocene that's a skinny little
period there then the Pliocene and the
Maya seen the alig Essene Eocene and
paleo scene I want to tell you a little
bit about the history of this stretch of
time because it's if you think about it
on the grand scale of things it's sort
of the the time period when things were
more or less like they are now in the
sense that there are mammals or in birds
being the dominant life forms whereas
before things were very different so
this time period started out with a bang
quite literally 65 million years ago an
asteroid that was ten kilometres across
or six miles across slammed into what's
now the Yucatan Peninsula at an impact
site called Chicxulub which means tail
of the devil
and that as we'll see is what probably
killed off the dinosaurs but there's
some interesting other things to be seen
in this map you'll notice that
Antarctica was not by itself it was
connected to Australia and a lot of
other features of the earth were
different in particular India had not
yet slammed into Asia and this probably
has something to do with why the climate
was so much warmer than although it
really is somewhat mysterious so what
happened this is a really beautiful
idyllic scene here that was painted by
someone at NASA
this looks like one of these new agey
posters but what it is it's one of the
biggest disasters that's ever happened
in the history of the herbs it's a nice
picture though so this enormous asteroid
ten kilometers across slammed into the
Carib Caribbean into the sea and
millions of tons of rock were thrown up
into the atmosphere lots of molten
quartz shot around the whole world
people see little droplets of quartz
that had been melted all around the
world
it sent wildfires all around the world I
you can if you go to my web site you can
if you're clever you can get to some
links that show the the spread of the
wildfires that people in theorized
happened at the time because of this
molten quartz and the what what that
caused was a huge pall of smoke that
wound up killing off the dinosaurs
here's a picture of the actual impact
you can see it came in at a slant they
know the slant that it came in it sent a
huge tsunami 50 to 100 meters tall
shooting over Texas unfortunately way
too early to do any good
sorry for any Texans in the audience I'm
not I'm not talking about all of you and
the other the big effect of it was that
it made the earth get dark for about a
year
plants basically were unable to
photosynthesize completely for about a
couple months and so the dinosaurs died
off and that set the stage for us well
not quite us so although I say things
are more or less like we're familiar
with in the sense that birds and mammals
were dominant birds had the upper hand
for a while there so in fact it's true
that the largest predators for several
million years were these eight foot tall
diet Reema's or terror cranes here you
see one eating a horse which makes it
look really huge until you remember that
horses were this tall at the time so
it's not it's not it's not like Godzilla
it's just it's just a pretty darn scary
bird but eventually somehow they died
out probably partially due to the
cooling that occurred and things became
a bit more like the recognisable earth
we know so 50 million years ago after 15
million years of warming up what
happened was that Antarctica separated
out from Australia and also shortly
thereafter not in this map the India hit
Asia of forming the Himalayas and the
huge Tibetan Plateau
and these things are two of the prime
suspects for why there's got colder
starting around then for one having
Antarctica being separate from other
land allows the ocean currents just to
keep going round and round Antarctica
which means that it doesn't need to ever
warm up I mean nothing's warming it up
where
when it was connected to other
landmasses all the currents had to loop
around and so warm water would be
hitting Antarctica and people think
that's why why it was kept warm before
but not now the Tibetan Plateau also has
a huge impact on the climate so the more
snow you have around the colder it gets
because snow is white and it reflects
light that's a basic instability in the
climate system when it gets cold it gets
white and that makes it colder when
conversely we're seeing now that as snow
is melting large portions of of the
north are warming up even faster because
because dirt picks up a lot more heat
than snow and in fact that if you think
about that it makes you wonder what in
the world is keeping things in balance
it's just the opposite of a feedback
mechanism that keeps things stable it's
a feedback mechanism that makes things
get get thrown off I could talk about
that but I got I guess I won't but I
will mention that there was a period
before the Cambrian called the period of
snowball earth when they believed the
whole earth was completely frozen over
due to this kind of out of whack
feedback so it's actually sort of
interesting what keeps things from going
haywire anyway what happened was that
Antarctica froze over about 14 million
years ago and it cooled down everywhere
and then at that time serious ice ages
started up here's a picture from around
the middle of the last one this is the
coldest part of the last ice age so you
see that a lot more ice in Antarctica
glaciers covering a lot of Europe and
North America and since then the ice is
melted and this is all happening in some
tiny little sliver there so if you think
about it this way you see that the earth
is really cold right now and it's very
unusually
chillie and so you might ask yourself oh
gee maybe a little global warming would
be just the thing and so that's a good
question I mean I think it really needs
to be be addressed so what is wrong with
global warming
really and the answer though is fairly
simple
the answer is it's happening way too
fast it's happening shockingly fast it's
not being warm or being cold that kills
off animals and plants it's the really
the change in temperature if the
temperature changes faster than they're
able to adapt to that's the problem and
this is the scariest graph of all as far
as I'm concerned this is a graph of
carbon dioxide concentration in the
Earth's atmosphere over the last few Ice
Ages the carbon dioxide really closely
tracks the temperature unfortunately I
don't have both graphs here the
temperature and the carbon dioxide but
they really match and so the last ice
age was was was here and then ice age
before that and you can see that the
amount of carbon dioxide during this
whole period of ice ages has been
oscillating in this in this band here
until 1860 when it shot up almost
vertically and is now about well it's
it's significantly higher than any any
of this recent history and that's
because of the man-made carbon dioxide
and you really need to zoom in to this
little last thousand years to begin to
appreciate how it's how its shot up it's
really just shot up in the last 150
years so what's happening is that we
have this period of ice ages alternating
with warm spells for quite a quite a
while and then WHAM right now things are
completely changing it's a whole new
ballgame so what's happening is that
species of lots of animals and plants
are trying to stay in the temperature
zones that they're used to and so the
ones north of the Equator are all moving
north they've done a survey of about
1,500
and they found that on average since
1950 they've been moving north six
kilometers per decade or about 10 miles
for decades so about a mile a year
animals are moving and plants are moving
north of course that's pretty tough for
plants to move that fast if you think
about it both well you know they died on
one end of their habitat they start to
grow on the other end but the real
problem is they can't keep up because
since 1975 the actual temperature bands
have been moving much faster than that
the temperature that is if you keep a
line of constant of equal temperature
and see how it marches north as things
warm up they've been moving north at
four kilometers per year or about I
guess that means six miles a year so so
so there's no way that most animal and
plant species can move that fast
especially of course you have to imagine
that at the same time you have people
with like cookie cutters ripping away
their habitat all over the place making
it harder for them to move around I
don't know if anyone's even mentioned
the idea of building a wall between us
and Mexico and how that will affect the
flow of animal life I don't think
they're planning to let the animals
through and you see this is just the
beginning so this is I'm talking about
now but you see that's we've we've seen
this one degree warming since 1900
roughly or about 0.8 degrees but that's
just the beginning here are all sorts of
different people's projections for
what's going to happen in the future but
you can see even though the more
conservative ones would be suggesting
about two degrees more warming in the
next century or possibly quite a bit
more like five so what we've seen is
climate moving along and then whoom
something happening much faster then
life-forms can adapt to that's the
problem with global warming from the
point of view of of the ecosystem as
opposed to just
people so it seems quite likely that
we're entering a whole new geological
era and in fact people have given a name
to it the Anthropocene that is it quite
possible that the ice ages are done with
now and we're entering a new period of
extreme warming and as with other
changes of from one geological period to
another we'll probably see a lot of
extinction
so in fact just around now in the last
few years we passed the temperature
record that was set a hundred and twenty
thousand years ago so I don't know if we
should have a party but Bowie but B so
the last time it's been this warm was
before the end of the last ice age and
if we just warm up one more degree which
will probably happen in another 50 years
the earth will be the hottest it's been
in 1.3 5 million years that's when the
ice ages began so in 2050 we'll have
we'll be out of the ice ages and into
some completely new territory so to
speak and people have done a lot of
different projections on what that's
going to mean for for animals and plants
and they estimate something like between
fifteen to forty percent of all species
are gonna get killed off and that's due
to the warming of course there's also
lots of other things going on so for
example as you know lots of things are
going on
90% of large fishes have been killed off
in the ocean over the last hundred years
we're seeing a major die-off in bird
species in America and we're seeing a
lot of amphibian species going extinct
about a hundred and fifty in the last 50
years all sorts of different things for
all sorts of different reasons and this
global warming is just one part of the
whole story so to understand what this
really means for the world we have to go
back even further in time and look at
what are called the mass extinction
events that is the times when
significant fractions of the species on
the planet of the earth have been wiped
out so I've just mentioned one of those
the the end of the dinosaurs but there
are others and here's a picture of them
so here's a graph we're taught the
present is over on the left hand side so
time is going this way and it's a graph
of extinctions these blue spikes are the
mass extinction events it's telling you
what percent not of species what extinct
but of general went extinct so general
is the plural of genus so we're Homo
sapiens so sapiens is our species and
then homo is the genus so there's also
like Homo neanderthalensis homo
Australopithecus all that all those
different variants of genus homo are
form form one genus and that's what
what's being counted here so the idea is
that if just a species goes extinct
there will be some other species that
are pretty similar they could then later
on adapt and branch out to fill the any
niche that was left but if a genus is is
gone that's more significant so at the
end of the age of the dinosaurs 30% of
general went extinct at the end of the
Eocene that's when the temperature
suddenly dropped
I'll just zip back there for you so here
that was a major extinction event and
you can see the the this particular one
is probably due to the drastic cooling
I'm not saying that all extinction
events are due to temperature change of
course be that the end of the dinosaurs
was something completely different but
that one's probably due to that the
sudden cooling and so that end of the
Eocene extinction event was the biggest
one since the end of the dinosaurs so
ten percent of general went extinct and
the current one is not plotted on here
on purpose because it's underway we
don't know what's going to happen
the real big one was at the end of the
permian the permian-triassic extinction
was the biggest of all as far as we can
tell about as you can see here about
fifty or forty-five or fifty percent of
general went extinct there's a book
that's available out in the lobby called
when the earth nearly died I think
something like that which is about that
and no one's quite sure why it happened
but one possibility is that is that it's
known there are huge amounts of volcanic
eruptions then there was some kind of I
guess a major tectonic event and it's
it's possible that there is a huge burst
of global warming due to the release of
a lot of carbon dioxide from from
volcanoes but there are other competing
theories for that and you can see that
there were other other major ones
earlier on this yellow curve is sort of
interesting that's a sort of averaged
out curve of extinctions and you can see
that on average the severity of
extinctions has been going down which
may actually mean that this idea of
survival of the fittest or of evolution
as a kind of advance is really has
something to it it may be that that life
is just getting better at adapting to
changes overall um let's see so what's
gonna stop things well luckily we'll run
out of oil yay so different people
predict that will happen at different
times don't worry I'm not running for
office so here are lots of different
projections you see that most of them
predict the peak oil usage sometime
around 2025 or so this is in millions of
barrels a day so right now or when this
chart was compiled it's 85 million
barrels of oil burnt a day it may go up
to about a hundred twenty or so and
it'll start going back down just so you
get a sense of how much agreement there
is on this that
red curve there is prepared by Exxon
whereas the green curve there is
prepared by British Petroleum which is I
guess green it's the right colour for
them there as oil companies go they're
green but but the point is that the
point of view of human politics it may
make a huge big difference whether the
oil more or less runs out around twenty
seventy five or twenty one twenty five
but from the point of view of the earth
as a whole it's not that big a deal I
guess it may affect how many species are
are killed off but the point is it's
gonna end pretty soon and so you could
take heart from this and say well you
know we're gonna be miserable of course
but at least those rise in the carbon
dioxide concentration of the Earth's
atmosphere is going to stop fairly soon
and then hopefully it will something it
will level off in times that we don't
completely send the climate totally out
of whack from what we're used to but
that's an open question so the question
is what can we burn next and we there's
a lot of stuff to burn so there are
three trillion barrels of oil left to
burn there is just one trillion barrels
of natural gas equivalent these are
converted to be the equivalent amount of
energy so there's less natural gas
there's a bit more coal four point five
trillion barrels worth of coal there is
about the same amount of tar sands four
point three billion trillion barrels tar
sands is this goopy Atari stuff that
with a lot of work you can extract the
oil
ah but dwarfing all of those utterly are
72,000 trillion barrels of stuff called
methane hydrates so I'm sure you all
hear about methane hydrates no you never
hear about methane hydrates
what are methane hydrates well in the
ocean in the northern latitude
at on the seafloor there's this weird
stuff that's a mixture of ice and
methane it's ice molecules that have
little methane molecules fit into the
empty space as you know ice is lighter
than water it's a very loose arrangement
of water molecules and there's enough
room to pop a methane in there and you
get this funny mix called methane
hydrate if you dig up a piece of that
and bring it up to the up into the air
it's unstable and the methane goes and
fizzes out you apparently you can see on
the web some movies of what it actually
looks like but it's a bunch of that
stuff down there and of course people
are scheming for how to dig it up and
burn it and that is precisely what you
should do if you want to first of all
keep the carbon burning economy going
and second of all if you want to make
global warming that's approximately ten
thousand times worse than what we see
now methane hydrates are pretty
interesting because there's so much of
them and you and and they're sort of
mysterious there are times when they
have impacted the climate and I should
just point out one I should go back a
bit so see what we're facing now is this
funny thing of a sudden spike of
temperature very rapid spike of
temperature and so it's interesting to
look around for other comparable but
events and see what happened to the
world when they're these spikes so if
you look at this graph you look at this
thing here but see that little thing
that's called the paleocene-eocene
thermal maximum or PETM it's not the
biggest change in temperature but it's a
very sudden change in temperature of
about two degrees that lasted for just
about a thousand years and it was a
warming spike and people wonder what
caused it and what they think caused it
was a methane burp a methane burp in
case a methane burp is when the methane
height
rates on the ocean floor somehow get
destabilized and amid all this methane
that's down there now methane's and even
more of a greenhouse gas than carbon
dioxide which is why in fact people are
seriously concerned about farting cows
I'm serious farting cows are a
substantial contributor to global global
warming but this massive release of
methane from methane hydrates was even
more important by far and they noticed
that there was significant extinctions
at the time I guess 30% of foraminifera
died out at the time for a mini ferrah
or forums or little little critters
float around in the sea that have a
calcium shell that eventually turned
into limestone when they die and fall to
the fall to the bottom so when you look
at limestone that's largely for man
different and other things like diatoms
so so what it meant was that there was a
sudden change in water temperatures
during that period that killed off lots
of those guys there have been probably
other extinctions that were caused by
massive release of methane and that's
the alternate theory for that big
die-off I mentioned the here the the
extinction at the end of the Permian
it's known that there was a huge burst
in warming so the two competing theories
are that carbon dioxide from volcanoes
or methane from a methane burp is
responsible and people are arguing about
it now anyway if you want to be really
paranoid you can make up scenarios where
people digging for methane hydrates
causes a methane burp I don't know how
likely that is but but if that doesn't
happen well maybe it will just burn it
and turn it into carbon dioxide and will
have more or less the same effect so the
question really is can we resist trying
to keep going our normal course of
burning and try to switch over to some
other sources of energy and of course
there are large industries devoted to
keeping business as usual I just like
this instance here so here's a note
placed by Phil
Kunie who is the chief of staff of the
White House Council on Environmental
Quality in 2002 this is a scientific
report that came to his desk about
global warming that was prepared by
various environmental agencies and here
he is watering it down saying you know
instead of the earth is undergoing a
period of relatively rapid change
changes it to the earth may be
undergoing a period a relatively rapid
change and so this is an example of how
various political forces are pushing us
away from realizing the significance of
what's going on when these notes were
discovered Phillip Cooney suddenly
decided he needed to spend more time
with his family
which apparently was Exxon he said he
wanted to see his family and I guess he
saw him for a while but then he went to
work for Exxon so in fact as you know
exons has a major role in setting up
this network of way of think-tanks that
try to downplay the importance of global
warming and so the question is can we
sort of see through the Ballona heat to
see what's really going on in time to
have any effect it may be it may well be
already too late really to have any
effect so we have to contemplate the
possibility of a mass extinction in the
long run you don't have to worry too
much about mass extinctions where by the
long run now I mean maybe periods of say
10 million years or so so a mass
extinction event is a pretty sad thing
here's a picture of the sea floor before
the biggest mass extinction event and
afterwards you can see the complete
impoverishment of of biodiversity that
happened then but then after tens of
millions of years it bounced back and it
became even more interesting so life
does have this amazing way of bouncing
back from these major disasters and it
even seems to get more interesting each
time so from that point of view which is
a very sort of cosmic or at least
long-term terrestrial perspective we
don't really need to worry we may
but it's very unlikely that we're gonna
kill off all life on earth and even if
we do who really there's nothing to
worry about there's lots more where that
came from there are about a hundred
billion stars in this galaxy if one of
them just manages to have life for a
while and it fizzles out while I'm sure
there's plenty of interesting stuff
happening elsewhere since I tend to
think on large scales that's usually how
I sort of calm myself down after reading
the newspapers you know so something
happened over there I'm actually usually
more interested what's happening over
there there's a very large black hole
there that's sort of more interesting to
me and really that galaxy isn't such a
big deal there are 10 billion of them in
the observable universe the observable
universe means not just what we can see
now but what we could ever see in other
words if you look back into time to the
Big Bang you see ten billion galaxies so
that means that there are about 10 to
the 21 stars in the universe of which
ours is just one so on the grand scale
of things it doesn't really matter to
anyone what happens except well for us
of course so we're sort of on our own
here I think and the question is can we
zoom out in time thanks
[Music]
thank you John we should ask you to give
a lecture on physics
yeah that's what I know something about
I would have liked to have talked about
math and physics but I thought I should
talk about something that might have
something decent do some good what I
love actually is that the you know
you're not only sideways in time you're
sideways for me too a lot of the kind of
general story about global warming
that's going on right now and we're all
but you know that Al Gore explains about
the the Gulf Stream and how that's gonna
cause the end of Europe if it shuts off
because of the water and the North
Atlantic and you're saying well yeah hmm
that's one of the theories and so we're
looking not only at I realize unstable
climate regime just looking at the
climate issue here and probably lots of
other major issues that we look at have
this kind of quality when you back off
from but there's also instability in the
understanding mm-hmm
and so we're always in a sense dealing
with a range of what might actually be
going on and this is part of what is
really really tough for policy makers
who are in a political framework and a
democracy to say well you know we're not
dead sure on this but we're trying to
reduce risk and so will it you know they
over position themselves and what one
would like to see is more of this
comfort with uncertainty that you put
out in this talk you introduced into the
whole political process and that's what
I especially love about what you've done
here we're just now collecting questions
while we're dealing with a few written
ones here and Kevin's sorting why don't
we have a hand raiser to somebody who's
got a question you just want to yell
right out right here yes
the question was which I'll give for the
television cameras what's what is the
actual doubt that is currently being
raised about the gulfstream theory of
the cooling of Europe so about what will
happen I think there's a huge amount of
uncertainty so the most of the research
is about what did happen and and what is
happening and so this this book is
actually pretty interesting by Marc
Bowen I guess it's on sale out there
it's it's called thin ice and it's about
people it's about the history of the
study of climate change I'm focusing on
people who are digging ice cores around
the tropics and it shows there's a lot
of controversy about the cause of this
Younger Dryas episode where first a
bunch of people thought that the what's
going on in the Atlantic was was really
the central the central determinant of
that Younger Dryas episode but but then
people started thinking that the Pacific
Ocean is much more significant partially
just because it's so much bigger in
determining global climate and so from
the point of view of the of this book
that that idea of the turning off of the
Gulf Stream being the cause of the
Younger Dryas is an old-fashioned theory
I'm sure it's still being debated and
I'm not up on the latest thing that's
one thing
it does it does it does affect it
because I think the only way we could
predict those kind of things is by
comparing them to previous events in
other words you know one is good enough
to build up a model of the Atlantic that
will you can you know press a button on
your computer and see what will happen
so they have to rely on this historical
evidence and I had had a I just changed
my transparent one of my transparencies
a couple days ago where I had said that
the Gulf Stream was what kept the what
kept Europe warm so a couple days ago I
said the Gulf Stream warms Europe and
then a climate scientist friend of mine
emailed me saying no we've just
discovered that that's not mainly yet
it's something much more complicated so
so that would also have a huge impact on
these questions so I unfortunately not
an expert on this I'll have to do some
reading myself one of the things that
I've seen as a result of this discussion
about climate change and realizing how
ferociously important it is is the
science is getting better better the
data collection is getting better and
better the theories are probably getting
better the models are getting better and
that's the stuff that you want to have
go ahead because then you get more
convergence Michael Berlin juror here
are you thank there says how has this
perspective affected your lifestyle or
what is the moral impact of all this I
feel guilty when I fly around giving
talks on global warming because I'm
using a lot of fuel flying around I this
is the first talk I've given on this
subject but I I mean I tried to burn as
little carbon as I can why I guess the I
guess more more than that just just form
for me I find myself trying to learn to
live with lots of different
temporal perspective simultaneously so I
spend a lot of time studying the real
long-term I could have given a lot of
fun a very fun talk about what's gonna
be the big problem in the future namely
all the stars burning out in the
universe expanding to the point where
each atom is completely isolated from
every other atom to me that's a pretty
interesting problem I just figured you
might have a little trouble getting to
concerned about that but but when you
think about these things on these widely
varying timescales you really do need to
somehow come to terms with the fact that
something can be fine on one timescale
and terrible on another time scale and
then fine on an even smaller time scale
and terrible on an even smaller time
scale and they're all they all coexist
and I can't really say what the impact
has been but it's somehow made me think
about things differently here's a
question without a name why do species
have trouble adapting to a few degrees
of variation in temperature humans seem
to adapt to a range of 10 or 20 degrees
even before technology human that's a
good question I think humans had
technology for quite a while a fur coat
and a fire and a cave is make makes
quite a difference if you've ever been
out in an Ice Age
I don't really know why the animals have
more trouble adapting than us apart from
the fact that we have technology I think
what's interesting that's very
interesting to me though is that we're
seeing now a strong selection for
species of certain sorts so I don't
think anyone's worried about rats and
pigeons for example they're they're
gonna do fine
cockroaches great so what I think we're
going to see is because not just the
problem of global warming but the bigger
problem in a sense of of loss of habitat
is that the species that will survive
are the ones that live well and good in
close proximity to humans and so those
will be mainly pests pets diseases cute
animals in zoos and animals that we eat
so in fact if you wanted to if you
wanted to keep rhinoceri from going
extinct you should probably start eating
them actually
but but not just by shooting them but
not but not by shooting them out in the
wild of course but by making farming
them so so again I don't really know the
full answer to your question but it is
going to become a very important issue
to see what what survives and what
doesn't and why that's a wonderful
that'll be one of the definitions of the
Anthropocene presumably for the for the
future geologists is they'll find the
species that all of which have the
characteristic of being like raccoons
that's right coyotes have moved into Los
Angeles there was one that was found in
Central recently
sorry might sounds flickering on and off
I think
and they're also around Washington DC
where my folks live and hopefully
they'll get some wolves in there to eat
all the deer that are eating all the
plants okay Gary wolf has a question
where are you Gary right here
and I'm gonna to broaden the question he
says can we cool the earth down by
painting it white please and this raises
the the whole issue of what I call
amelioration schemes there's some of
them in Jim Bluff locks wonderful book
the Revenge of Gaia which just came out
in the US and there's some folks over
here at Lawrence Livermore labs who've
been looking at some of the kind of what
if you while you're waiting for the run
out of oil and and deciding not to do
the clathrates the methyl hydrates and
so on what do you do to keep things in
hand for a while and one of the
suggestions that one just paint the
earth white certainly can paint roofs
white and it would be sensible to do
that anyway
highways going to be interesting right
you stole my suggestion which is don't
use black asphalt it's actually not that
terribly hard to make highways be white
this isn't gonna be enough but it's
something that's pretty doable yeah it'd
be fun to do you just say okay in the
deal you live in this county you have a
white roof and we drive on white streets
so they're trying to make the roofs in
Los Angeles white really that's finally
happening John for years people wanted
to paint the roofs white and the
neighbor
said no it's too bright and they had
rules against painting a roof point
anyway other amelioration things one of
them is to go out to Al Gore's favorite
point which is the Allah grant one point
between it's the gravitationally stable
point between here and the Sun where
among other things would be swell they
have a camera getting a real-time photo
of the earth with the Sun behind it so
it's the full disk of the earth with
turning and having weather and and also
giving temperature readings which you
would like to have but it would also be
possible to and this is one of the
things that Jim Lovelock mentioned to
basically have something which right at
that point expands out and cuts off some
of the light coming from the Sun into
the earth and a disc of you know very
light material seven miles in diameter
which be relatively easy to spin out put
there and spin out could cut the amount
of sunlight reaching the earth enough to
head off some of the warming that we're
having just seven miles would be enough
that's I'm waving my hands real fast
here yeah anyway I mentioned this the Al
Gore a couple of weeks ago and he went
batshit he think oh you said oh that's a
real good experiment to run let's just
see if we can you know change the whole
earth at once and he was not in favor of
doing that but you can imagine things
getting desperate enough to where by
some international agreement because
obviously it would take that but likely
kind of agreement we have about
Antarctica being the continent for
science and so on okay let's you know
put something there move it out a little
bit see if it helps if it helps move it
out a little bit more back off if it's
less because you could control it from
there this is kind of thing appeal to
you at all ah I don't think anything
appeals to me about global warming yes
so so I mean they're all yeah you run a
big risk of course when you start
messing with things even further so I
but but we run a huge risk not messing
with things further so I think instead
of me saying what I think I would like I
think I just spend most of my time
trying to figure out what people are
likely to do so if if if somehow the
global warming becomes a very noticeable
issue people will start pushing for
these technological solutions and I
think that will just be in line with
what's been going on ever since
technology began namely that we acquire
more and more control over our
environment and eventually I think we're
sort of headed that way the earth is
gonna be our our baby to take care of as
as well as we can that's the idea of the
Anthropocene and whether a particular
measure winds up helping or ruining
things you know it can be very hard to
tell well in line with the enthroned as
we had a talk from rusty Schweickart
several years ago in this series on the
what he referred to as the asteroid and
threat over the next hundred thousand
years that 165 million years ago that
kind of things that happen again anytime
except that now humans are in position
to be able to detect ones that are on a
collision course
go out there and actually divert them it
doesn't take a whole lot of energy or
time to divert an incoming asteroid if
you have a couple of years advance
warning well among other things this
just completely throws off the whole
past because in the past we've had these
big asteroids coming in from time to
time and bashing the earth that's right
and in the Anthropocene that doesn't
happen anymore if we get our act
together that's what we yeah we won't
have to worry about asteroids too much
yeah an interesting thing is that
there's a lot of argument about how many
major extinctions were caused by large
rocks hitting the earth there's pretty
good evidence for the for the end of the
dinosaurs I mean there's a crater there
that happened at the right time there's
still though a lot of controversy about
whether that was really the
thing that did them in there's some
people who say hey look we can see
they're dying out even before that for
all the earlier extinctions it's much
more mysterious there's so they're sort
of different camps there's some people
to think that asteroids are our major
cause of these mass extinction events so
and one of the cuter theories long lines
these asteroid impacts happen more or
less regularly whenever the Sun goes
through the plane of the galaxy because
that shakes off shake perturbs asteroids
and if that works that's true then we
can expect the next one in ten million
years so then so there could be another
big one to worry about in ten million
years but we should have lots to worry
about before that other stuff before
then yeah okay here's a question from
will Hurst worry well will by the way is
the founding sponsor of this series
Richmond thank you for that and for this
question how accurate are any computer
models of climate since we can't predict
weather more than a week ahead isn't
this all basically pretty profoundly
chaotic well a lot of chaotic Wiggles
averaged out in the medium term so I
think we're getting pretty decent at
predicting climate over period of the
next hundred years we're terrible at
predicting it for longer periods than
that so these big changes that I was
showing on my big graph like the Eocene
warming up and then cooling down we
really have very little clue about those
kind of things people have pretty good
models actually for what cause causes
the ice ages it's basically just due to
variations in the Earth's orbit so again
it depends a lot on the timescales
you're talking about and of course for
political purposes it's the next hundred
years is what you care about a lot and I
think it's just pretty clear to me that
we're headed for warming for the next
hundred years you just need to look at
at that graph of carbon dioxide
concentration and I think that's that
sort of says it whether it's going to be
just one degree or five degrees while
then you have to start arguing about
your climate models and I'm not an
expert in climate models either so I
can't I can't really say well I'd rather
say that and the political perspective
makes you look at the next hundred years
if only the next in fact one of the
things that our grandchildren I
mentioned or the summer deprecatingly
but I don't mean it because he said he
wants to do one of these talks in the
series and that the subject would be how
basically long-term thinking and
long-term responsibility can be
reintroduced into the whole political
electoral process because right now we
tend to be focusing on the next election
which is not in a hundred years
no and the results of it don't last for
a hundred years
well here's a question from Phil Cass
where are you somewhere here so he says
that's an awful lot of methane hydrate
yeah but isn't it already sublimating
isn't it likely to end up in the
atmosphere before we get a chance to
burn it
I mean free the oceans are getting
warmer are they gonna have a cause a bra
ah well I suppose warming oceans could
cause a methane burp then I guess that
would be a kind of thing we really need
to look back at the geological record
and I guess the big problem there is
that it's very hard to tell whether
warming oceans caused a methane burp or
whether our methane burp caused warming
oceans that's the problem with a lot of
these geological things you see hey look
there's a lot of methane and the oceans
are warm but you need to know things on
a very fine scale to know to know which
caused which I haven't heard of any
evidence that methane is sublimating out
yet well there's another question what
is the origin of the methane hydrates as
their biological origin for them I'm
sorry I don't know that either it must
be biological because because the carbon
cycle is largely run by by biological by
biological entities and I'm sorry I
don't know how it all got down there
that's terrible I should know but I
don't
I've seen a picture by the way you were
mentioned there are things in the web if
you look up I think hydrates or
clathrates they're also called Li you
see pictures of a person holding this
white chunk of obviously ice in their
hand with flames coming out of it and
yes you can just you can just take a
hunk of this stuff hold a match over and
it will burn yeah but because of the
methane coming out there's an image of
the earth enzo z asks plotted against
the Earth's polarity reversals is there
a causal relationship between Earth's
fluctuations of a temperature and
Earth's polarity and lower and how about
the Herbet of the milky way around the
galactic core every what is it 26 he has
a thousand that's not right 26 million
years 26 million years any relationship
there so the by polarity I guess he
means that he or she means the magnetic
polarity the magnetic field of the earth
flips erratically I don't think there's
any correlation between that and climate
it was right when it's happening there's
not much of a magnetic field and so
there's be a lot more cosmic rays
hitting ground no that would be pretty
scary I don't really know how people
have noticed extinctions due to due to
that but I have never heard of any
extinctions being due to that about the
about the Sun and earth going around the
galaxy that is this theory that I just
mentioned a little while ago that that
periodically
we're not going around perfectly in
plain with the rest of the galaxy so so
twice around we go through more thick
stuff that shakes us loose some comets
and asteroids from their usual orbits
and then they might be more likely to
smack into us so people have done a lot
of studies where they look at big old
craters and plot the frequency of their
occurrence with this so-called galactic
year and they seem to see that there is
some kind of match up there so as I said
that means we have to worry in 10
million years from now but notice on
your website you always have interesting
material of whatever current in the
images and data coming from Mars is
what's your interest in Mars
oh part of it is just that it looks cool
it's nice it's nice to have some other
planets to look at but part of I guess
one of my another point if I guess make
a political point while I'm at it
the idea of sending people to Mars is
really ridiculous and they're planning
to spend billions and billions of
dollars sending people to Mars so part
of my point is that by sending these
machines to Mars you can see everything
that you would see anyway and it's my
mind man space travel is a bit like
putting a goldfish on Mount Everest you
know you say well we did it the goldfish
has experienced what it's like to be on
Mount Everest but it's not really all
that it's not really worth it on that
note thank you very much John guys
thanks
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]